Hi, this is Dr. Carter.
Again, we're going to talk about the difficulty that modern medicine has in treating chronic
disease.
I'm not going to spend a lot of time on this because you're literally on this course because
you understand that.
So this is part of our educational piece, educating ourselves to understand that where doctor
is in here just to solve all our problems always.
And we need to dig into this ourselves.
It doesn't take much investigation to realize that chronic diseases is climbing like crazy.
It's this is just a chart on the dollars and billions of dollars just in the US that
has spent on chronic and autoimmune diseases that is just going through the roof.
Quick snapshot of modern autoimmune diseases.
One of every six Americans, 16% has an autoimmune disease.
And this is just a full diagnosis of an autoimmune disease.
How many other people, maybe over 50% of our population, many functional doctors believe
that literally by 2025 to 2030, literally everybody's going to have an autoimmune disease.
The amount of poisons that are environment, biotoxins, we're dealing with the chemicals
that we're having to deal with are bodies of inability to detoxify all factor into this.
The rise and rate of autoimmune disease cannot be disputed.
You know, medicine does not have an answer to this.
They might be fantastic at treating, you know, you get into car accident, you break your
arm, something happens, you know, with heart disease, getting in and getting critical,
crisis care, nobody's better than that.
So you know, don't discount the benefits of modern medicine.
It's fantastic.
But when you're dealing with with chronic things, why do they seem to fall short?
Well, my thought is the problem has to do with cause.
Nobody's dealing with this.
What?
Certainly nobody in modern medicine is dealing with this.
If you go in, let's say you have Hashimoto's, you're going to talk to your medical doctor.
Why do I have Hashimoto's?
How could I deal with this?
How could I get to the cause?
You're either going to get a blank stare or you're going to get a, well, we don't know.
This is just a disease that we don't understand fully or you're going to look like made to
feel like you're wearing a tinfoil hat or something like that.
So the cause is complex, so that makes it even more difficult.
You have to find a functional doctor that's going to dig into your barriers, your gut barriers,
your brain barriers, different nutrient deficiencies, different insulin surges, different functions
of your organs, your liver, your detoxification pathways, your ability to get rid of poisons
that you're exposed to, change your lifestyle at your exposure to poisons, it's going to
be less.
Dealing with pituitary fatigue, pituitary access issues, inflammation of your brain, adrenal
fatigue, food sensitivities that can up-regulate your immune system and cause an immune flare,
balances in your hormones, dealing with chronic infections that you might not even know
you have.
Mycotoxins are a hidden Lyme disease and not to mention all the stresses that we deal with
in our environment.
This is a complex issue.
It's not easy.
If you think that dealing with a chronic disease is easy, I know you as patients don't because
you've been dealing with this for a long time, but I do want to say to practitioners listening
to this.
It's a simple fix for people.
And I don't want any patients to think that you just are one supplement sure to solving
all your problems.
And this is, you found the key ingredient that's going to make everything go away.
It's about managing it.
And I've said it a hundred times, it's not about making these diseases go away.
You're never going to be completely cured of an autoimmune disease.
That's just a fallacy.
You have to understand I have to know how to manage this, to keep my flares down and keep
in a relative state of health, and that's the whole goal of this.
And that's the whole goal of what we're going to be studying through this.
So I said this was going to be short, and I meant it, we'll move on and we'll start digging
it into these factors and how we're going to uncover these things and give you the best
approach to health.
Thanks so much.